to make this work we really have to have
people join in their families families
join in their communities and the
communities to build their states and
their overall so I do think we must get
this toxic environment fixed and without
that there just won't be enough
motivation to choose the right food to
choose the right physical activity to
get the dead of dividend from the
science and nutrition in this area so
that I do want to emphasize and to
acknowledge I need government I need the
environmental engineers I almost need a
new description or definition of what it
is to be an American who takes on the
responsibility to optimize their health
go for longevity and don't hurt
themselves yes this is a an epidemic and
I think where we start since it appears
that the you know where the overeating
and the diabetes meet seems to be
creating the greatest new harm so of
giving a priority to fix the diabetes
obesity problem and that is worldwide I
mean it's tragic to see third world
countries now because they just get
exposed to too much fat and too many
excess calories that they're the least
prepared to deal with this epidemic of
weight gain causing diabetes and obesity